the cats hi it's Michelle from lab -
beauty science here your festive beauty
and skincare science nerd christmas is
coming and i'm getting a whole bunch of
questions about what would make an
appropriate skincare gift I had all
these grand plans to wear like really
cute reindeer antlers but I think I
might have left them at work from like
Christmas last year so I have these cat
ears instead but cats aren't really that
festive I know it sounds a bit like my
dog ate my homework I really tried I
have tinsel I have this festive Santa
thing I have some alcohol I'm wearing
the tinsel it's really itchy
and I feel like it's not really worth it
cuz you can barely see it on-screen
anyway this is the best I could do in
this situation I don't know if the
reindeer antlers would fit in the frame
anyway maybe if s that like this I have
this reindeer antler ring instead which
makes me super Christmassy right if your
friends and family know that you're a
skincare nut you might be getting a lot
of questions about what to give people
in terms of skincare or maybe you have
someone in your life who is obsessed
with skincare and you really want to
give them something special so I thought
I'd do a video discussion about what
sorts of products are safe and
appropriate and give you some gift ideas
so that your shopping will be a bit
easier if you liked this video I'd
really appreciate it if you gave it a
thumbs up and subscribe to my channel
alright first off is skincare a good
gift this is really itchy I'm gonna take
it off this is gonna become like
stripped Christmas strip skincare
is skincare even a good gift so this is
a pretty controversial topic and I asked
a bunch of you guys on Instagram what
you thought I got a whole lot of mixed
responses skincare isn't like an all-out
bad idea like gifting a pet did you hear
that truffle not everyone wants a
truffle as a Christmas gift
oh I'm sorry truffle it's someone
interested you loved being on camera
you're always trying to be on camera why
don't you want to be on camera when I
actually want you to be on camera and I
think whether or not it's a good gift
depends on the exact type of skincare
you're gifting and the person getting it
because skincare is a pretty personal
sort of choice so I thought I'd come up
with some general guidelines to help you
work out if you should even be gifting
skincare to someone alright guideline
number one don't give someone skin care
for treating a problem like acne or
aging unless they specifically ask for
something in that category I think this
is a rule that should never be broken
because it can come across like you're
telling them that they look old or that
they're really spotty and they need to
fix it and it's just really awkward it's
in the same category of faux pas or like
female relative neg it's like when you
assume that someone's pregnant or you
give someone to uterine or you suggest
that maybe they should eat a bit less or
give them tips on how to bind that
big-ass feet so that they can find a
husband this is a true story I have a
Chinese grandmother my feet are size 36
for all of you single men out there who
are looking for a wife with small feet
my second guideline is if they've ever
said something about sensitive skin or
allergies or rosacea then skin care is
probably somewhere where you should
tread pretty lightly if someone has
sensitive skin then they probably have
this massive long checklist of what they
look for and avoid in skin care they
probably avoid fragrance and some of the
common preservatives as well so that
means if you
want to give them a safe skincare
present then you'll generally left with
really boring skincare products like a
tub of Vaseline or medicated cream which
is probably useful but not really the
sort of gift that really does much as a
gift it's kind of like gifting someone
cling wrap or toilet paper
practically speaking it's really great
because you'll definitely use it but in
terms of what you want to find under the
Christmas tree it's probably not high on
the list it's like two circles in a Venn
diagram that just don't intersect it's
probably also not a great idea to give
someone skin care if they have really
strong opinions about skin care if you
buy them a trendy new product then they
either probably already have it all if
they've already decided that they don't
want it in this situation you should
probably ask them if they actually want
a particular product before you go out
and buy it or just ask them what they
want I personally don't like surprise
gifts because I have pretty much never
gotten anything I actually wanted so I'm
pretty jaded about the whole idea of
surprises but I know that a lot of
people have had better experiences in
this particular area so the surprise
factor is important for some people and
obviously this will just kill it oh so
much that's why no one wants you okay so
if you've decided that gifting skincare
is a good idea for this particular
person here are some safe skin care gift
ideas that I've come up with this video
isn't sponsored but I do feature some
products that I've received as PR
samples in the past a safe skincare gift
would be a gift card to their favorite
store this is obviously a safe option
but it feels a bit less personal and it
seems a bit lazy as well but in terms of
giving them something that they'll
actually use and treasure and that boy
doesn't rot in a corner then you can't
really beat this you can make it a bit
more personal if you give them like a
small inexpensive item to go with the
gift card and there's some really cute
options out there so for example meka
which is a store in australia they have
this gift card which comes with a little
product as well so this year it is a
hydrating mist so that makes it a little
bit
less I've given you money my next
guideline for goose skin Caicos is that
body products are generally a lot safer
than face products face skin is a bit
thinner and it's a lot more sensitive so
it's more prone to breakouts if we've
got the wrong products and it's a lot
more visible as well if you do happen to
have a reaction most people are a lot
less specific about what goes on their
body rather than their face especially
when it comes to things like fragrance
so you can have a bit more fun with this
with less of a risk unless of course the
person has really sensitive skin or
they're sensitive to fragrance in which
case probably just don't go there body
products are also a good idea because
they tend to be larger volume products
that get used up very quickly so if you
give them travel size products then it's
good for traveling as well because it
tends to be in larger containers and so
carrying it around is a bit of a pain in
terms of luggage most Beauty people do
prefer travel size products if they're
not sure about a product there's less
waste if they don't like a product and
most things are better than hotel
products although I've been to a few
really nice hotels which had like
L'Occitane products anyway body products
are generally a lot safer some of the
products that might make good gifts are
body moisturizers hand cream shower gel
nail care hand sanitizer
one of the brands that I really like for
body skin care guess is the body shop I
actually did a sponsored post with them
recently showing off their Christmas
range I was actually going to include
them in this video before they
approached me to do a sponsored post I
really like them because they have a
bunch of gifts which partially go
towards charity they're really nicely
presented as well so you don't have to
put too much effort into wrapping them
and making them look good and they have
sets with lots and lots of different
price points which makes it really
convenient for things like Secret Santa
gifts so the body shop have a bunch of
different gift sets so for example if
you know that your person really likes
strawberry you can buy them a whole pack
of different strawberry stuff and most
of these packs have lots of convenient
travel sizes if you don't know what sent
your gifts tea likes then you can also
get like a variety set so that hopefully
there's at least a few things in there
that they'll enjoy there's also a lush
which has really good one use products
like bath bombs and bath
which means that if your person doesn't
really like the product again there's
not that much waste my favorites are the
bath melts they're really moisturizing
but before you get a lush product for
the bath check that they actually have a
bath and that they take baths otherwise
I guess they do smell really nice anyway
so you can put them in your sock drawer
but probably better to ask another good
category of gift is the advent calendar
they usually have lots of travel size
products and just a nice range for your
gift II to try lots of stores have
really nice advent calendars you can
also get one from their favorite brand
The Body Shop has some as well
if you're feeling quite creative you can
also make your own DIY calendar you can
buy a calendar box from somewhere like
Amazon and then just put little travel
size products into it to give your gift
e something pretty unique if you want to
give face products then I think the best
ones are the more generic products that
don't stay on your face for too long so
things like cleansers makeup remover
masks and lip balm are pretty good for
that you can also try gifting a fancy
skincare set ideally it would be
fragrance free if you want to go for
something pretty luxe then you can try a
more clinical sort of skincare brand for
example synergy from Australia they've
come out with a few gift sets that are
really nicely packaged in travel bags
and they contain products that are
pretty suitable for a lot of different
skin types so this one has a cleanser
it's got a nice in amide which is pretty
much good for everything and a daily
moisturizer which has sun protection in
it another one of my favorite brands
ultra suta calls has also come out with
a whole bunch of different skincare sets
they've come up with a hydrating set
that pretty much all skin types can use
you can also try gifting skincare tools
so things like body sponges face washing
towels face halo microfiber cloths and
it's especially good if it's the
category of tool that you should be
changing every once in a while as well
and hopefully it can still be a little
bit fun so probably not like cotton pads
but maybe some reusable cotton pads
would be good also maybe a silicone mask
like the ones you can get from Daiso
which was the suggestion i got from
someone on instagram thank you for that
one in the sort of middle price range
section you might try giving a jade
roller or a pair of tweezers because
tweezers are
really useful and go missing a lot if
they're a massive skincare and Asian
earth then maybe they might like a
hydration tool like the way skin if you
want to go really high-end there may be
a device like the Panasonic microcurrent
tool or the new face or the zip I
probably wouldn't gift a cleansing brush
because I feel like people tend to
overuse them a lot but maybe something
that's silicone like the foyer finally I
think gifts that aren't strictly
skincare but sort of skincare adjacent
are really good as well you can try
gifting them a spa voucher so it's
something that's quite indulgent that
they probably wouldn't buy for
themselves there are a few versions
available where you can let the person
choose which spa to go to travel bags
are really good as well I feel like you
can't really get enough travel bags and
they come in so many different price
points as well if you want to go more
fancy than you can give them like a
monogrammed one but even inexpensive
transparent ones come in handy a lot for
things like plane trips skin care
storage is also something that a lot of
skin care addicts really need so things
like a skin care shelf which like this
one which I'm currently using for
everything but skin care there's also a
rotating shelf that I've been really
fond of which works really well if your
skin care addict has limited storage
space acrylic drawers are really nice as
well you can get some from Muji which
are really solid really high-quality and
sort of a splurge if they're really
nerdy there may be gifting them a
skincare book might be good I'm enjoying
this one called Beyond soap at the
moment I also have an e-book out which
you can give as a gift the lab muffin
guide to basic skincare Beauty science
Beauty science all you hate science
there's tons of other skincare adjacent
gifts as well things like skincare
fridges light up mirrors humidifiers
silk pillowcases and even something
small like skincare stickers that you
can put on your skin care to say when
they've been opened so that's a rundown
of the skin care gift ideas I came up
with hopefully that comes in handy if
you're planning to give skincare to
someone I'm sure you guys have lots of
ideas as well if there's something I
left out that you think would be a
fantastic idea then leave it in the
comments below
good luck with your gift shopping don't
forget to take some time out
yourself don't rush around too much if
you liked this video I really appreciate
it if you gave it a thumbs up and
subscribe to my channel you can also
follow me on Instagram and check out my
blog for more articles about the science
behind beauty products
say goodbye trouble
you